jewel labs was once one of the most
valuable startups in the world
valued in 2018 at 38 billion dollars
but most of that has gone up in smoke in
2020 altria which holds a 35
stake in the company said joule is now
worth less than 5 billion
joule's been a fascinating story to
cover because
it rose and fell so quickly it really
turned the
tobacco industry upside down overnight
jewel is fighting for its life laying
off in the past year around three
quarters of its employees
it faces hundreds of lawsuits alleging
the company marketed its products
to teens if you think you can come into
this county
and you can harm our youth and we're not
going to fight you back
you're wrong its product's popularity
with young people has become the
liability that's a threat to the
company's viability
in 2015 jewel introduced a new vaporizer
the company was founded by stanford
university graduate students adam bowen
and james monsis adam and i smoked
we tried to quit and we failed for us
giving up smoking required an
alternative
which did not exist at the time we
founded jewel labs to invent one
adam bowen and james monsis developed a
product that was unlike any e-cigarette
that came before it
it had a cool sleek slim design
that looked like a usb flash drive and
they were going for an aesthetic like an
apple product they wanted
to have something that was high-tech
cool that people would want to be seen
holding the secret sauce was also
what was inside it it contained a
nicotine
salt solution that delivered a really
powerful punch of nicotine
but without the throat harshness that
you might otherwise expect from an
e-cigarette at the time
in 2016 legacy tobacco firms with their
similar looking products led the pack in
e-cigarette sales
that year joule sold 2.2 million devices
it was still a small player
but in 2017 that changed joule's sales
numbers soared that year
increasing nearly eight-fold it was
available
in more and more stores many convenience
stores and gas stations
so that helped propel its growth and
jewel also marketed it they
gave jewel packages to celebrities for
as little as a dollar
to try to get them to use it and be seen
using it in the hopes that
celebrities and other social media
influencers would help spread the word
as joule's own data would later disclose
some of the customers its product was
attracting
had never smoked cigarettes before by
the end of 2018
jewel labs had captured 68 percent of
the 1.9
billion dollar u.s e-cigarette market
prominent investors took notice
a fundraising ground that summer brought
the startup's value to about 16 billion
dollars
but 2018 was also the year jewel found
itself in the crosshairs of regulators
the food and drug administration opened
an investigation into jewel
after parents and school administrators
sounded the alarm about
youth vaping after two decades of
declining teen cigarette smoking
a 2018 survey revealed that the share of
high schoolers who were vaping had
increased significantly
when the regulator in charge of
the e-cigarette industry targets
your company that's a big deal
and jewel took a series of steps that
year to try to show
that they were taking the problem
seriously the first thing they did was
they said that they would work with
retailers
to ensure that at the point of sale
kids weren't getting access to jewel and
other e-cigarettes
but the fda wasn't satisfied it
conducted an inspection at the company's
headquarters
and the agency threatened to take
flavored e-cigarettes off the market
entirely because they were attracting
underage users jewel responded
by voluntarily pulling most of their
sweet and fruity flavors
out of brick and mortar retail stores so
those flavors
included mango cucumber and creme brulee
for example jewel also suspended its
social media marketing
in the u.s despite all this jules
valuation
soared to 38 billion dollars when altria
the maker of marlborough bought a
significant minority stake in the
company
altria wanted to get a piece of the
growing e-cigarette market
and ultra's own e-cigarette products
were not that successful
altria got in at an inauspicious moment
after making the nearly 13 billion
dollar investment in jewel
things began to unwind rite aid the
third largest u.s pharmacy chain
announced it would stop
selling e-cigarettes in its stores in
september 2019
jules ceo kevin burns stepped down he
was replaced by altria
executive kc crossweight that same month
in a blow to the company's overseas
ambitions china
the world's biggest tobacco market
halted jules sales
just days after its launch there and in
the u.s governors called for immediate
bans on all flavored e-cigarettes
common sense says if you don't know
what you are smoking don't smoke it
at the same time the entire nicotine
vaping industry faced
a full-blown pr crisis new vaping
numbers
illnesses top 1000 with deaths on the
rise some patients actually suffered
toxic chemical burns
to their lungs and airways as if being
exposed to a chemical spill
after hospitals throughout the country
linked at least eight deaths to vaping
us health officials urged americans to
stop using any and all
e-cigarette products while authorities
investigated the cause
the illnesses were eventually linked to
marijuana vaping devices containing
vitamin e oil
not to e-cigarettes like joule but the
damage to vaping's image
continued to be felt and the tsunami of
bad news for juul
continued jul's new ceo halted most u.s
advertising
then stopped all u.s sales of jewels
sweet and fruity flavors
state attorneys general across the
country sued jewel for
deceptive marketing of its products
jewel basically took a page from big
tobacco's playbook
by marketing its products in a manner
that was appealing to underage youth
in court filings experts allege that
even though the models jewel used and
its 2015 promotional materials were in
their 20s
they appeared in poses and behaviors
more characteristic
of underage teens than mature adults
cross wheat was grilled by lawmakers for
the marketing methods joule employed
before he arrived
we are focused on combating underage
access because i know it puts it all at
risk
if we don't make progress here sir how
do i trust what you say
my actions so far since i've joined um
support our recognition that more needed
to be done more done
with fewer people amid a sharp drop in
sales in the fall of 2020
joule continued to shrink its workforce
down to around a thousand
from its high of just over 4 000 and
pulled out of most overseas markets
and altria wrote down the value of its
staking joule by
around 11 billion dollars everything
hinges
on an fda review that will determine
whether or not jules products can stay
on the market
or whether they have to come off it
presented a real potential for a public
health benefit
um you know getting adult cigarette
smokers off
of cigarettes which kill 480 000
people a year you know offered a lot of
promise it was interesting to investors
it was compelling to public health
experts
but at the same time joule presented an
incredible risk
federal data now show that youth vaping
is decreasing
the ceo said joule is now focused on its
founding principle
to help smokers move away from
cigarettes but that joule needs to prove
it can be trusted
if it can do that crossway said jewel
has a lot of potential in the long
term but that will be an uphill battle